the #1 probiotic
fat burner in America.
♪.
RACHEL: CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION REPORTEDLY FLAGGING A
SMALL NUMBER OF AFGHAN REFUGEES
FOR CONCERN DURING THEIR VETTING
AT MILITARY BASES AROUND THE
WORLD.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY,
FBI AROUND THE STATE DEPARTMENT
HAD A PHONE CALL FRIDAY DISCUSS
THE SCREENING EFFORTS.
LET’S BRING IN FORMER ACTING
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
KEN CUCCINELLI.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU HEARD OUR
LAST SEGMENT.
GOOD MORNING.
>> I DID.
RACHEL: AN INTERPRETER TRAPPED
BASICALLY WE’RE FEARING FOR HIS
LIFE BUT THE FRUSTRATION FOR ME
WASN’T TAKEN OUT BUT HE AND
OTHER GUESTS THAT WE HAD THIS
WEEKEND SAID MANY AFGHANS HAVE
BEEN EVACUATED WHO DID NOTHING
TO HELP AMERICA.
WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON?
WHY IS THAT HAPPENING AND WHY
AREN’T THOSE PEOPLE WHO GOT OUT
VETTED TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY PRIORITIZED AS PEOPLE
WHO HELPED AMERICA?
>> WELL, THERE IS CERTAINLY A
LOT THERE.
FIRST OF ALL, TO THE FIRST PART
OF YOUR QUESTION, THE REASON
PEOPLE ARE COMING OUT WHO DID
NOTHING TO HELP THE UNITED
STATES WHILE OTHERS ARE STUCK
THERE IS BECAUSE THIS WASN’T AN
ORDERLY WITHDRAWAL.
RACHEL: RIGHT.
>> WE COLLAPSED OUR SECURITY
PERIMETER BEFORE WE TOOK THE
PROTECTIVE STEPS THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN TAKEN FIRST.
AND THIS WAS PART OF A
CONDITIONAL WITHDRAWAL THAT HAD
BEEN PREVIOUSLY PLANNED UNDER
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION THAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION THREW OUT
APPARENTLY JUST BECAUSE IT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S PLAN.
THAT IS THE SIMPLE ANSWER TO WHY
YOU SEE THIS SORT OF CHAOTIC
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DONE NOTHING FOR THE UNITED
STATES ARE GETTING OUT AND
ACTUALLY ARRIVING IN THE UNITED
STATES WHILE PEOPLE WHO HELPED
THE UNITED STATES ARE NOW
TRAPPED AND BEING HUNTED BY THE
TALIBAN.
RACHEL: RIGHT.
>> SO I WOULD ALSO NOTE FOR
THESE PEOPLE COMING HERE, BEING
BROUGHT HERE SO QUICKLY, LOOK
THE VETTING PROCESS IS HARD.
IT IS ESPECIALLY HARD IN
COLLAPSED NATIONS WITH COLLAPSED
GOVERNMENTS LIKE THIS ONE.
THIS IS AN 18 TO 24 MONTH
PROCESS WITH 14 DIFFERENT STEPS
AND THEY’RE SUPPOSEDLY DOING IT,
WHICH THEY’RE NOT, IN DAYS.
I WOULD TELL YOU IT HASN’T BEEN
REPORTED ANYWHERE, THEY SET UP
AS I UNDERSTAND IT A DHS TASK
FORCE HEADED BY A GUY NAMED JOHN
LAFFERTY.
A CAREER OFFICIAL WHO WAS
REMOVED BY HIM FROM HIS ASYLUM
POSITION BECAUSE HE WAS
BASICALLY CONDUCTING HIS OWN
EFFORTS INCONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH, HE
WOULD LITERALLY CHANGE FINAL
DOCUMENTS BEFORE THEY WOULD GO
OUT, IN MY VIEW TO SET TRAPS FOR
US.
THAT IS WHO THEY HAVE LEADING
THIS.
THEY HAVE A RADICAL DEEP STATER
LEADING THIS EFFORT FOR DHS THE
QUALITY OF THE VETTING HAS GONE
THROUGH THE FLOOR.
RACHEL: OF COURSE.
THIS IS WHY WE HAD SUCH, THAT IS
WHY WE HAD SUCH A BACKLOG OF
INTERPRETERS ALL YEAR, PETE
HEGSETH HAS BEEN TRYING TO SHINE
LIGHT ON THIS TO EXPEDITE IT.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS IT
TAKES TIME.
ALL OF SUDDEN IT DOESN’T TAKE
TIME.
WHY, KEN, I DON’T HAVE ENOUGH
TIME YET, WHY HAVEN’T THEY BEEN
PLACED TO OTHER COUNTRIES WHERE
WE WAIT FOR THEM TO BE PROPERLY
VETTED BEFORE BEING BROUGHT
HERE, PROBABLY LESS CULTURE
SHOCK FOR A LOT OF THEM IF
THEY’RE IN SOME MIDDLE EAST
COUNTRY THAT IS AN ALLY OF OURS?
>> THERE YOU GO THINKING
LOGICALLY.
THERE IS A WORLDWIDE CONSENSUS
HOW TO DEAL WITH REFUGEE ISSUES
AND IT IS REGIONALLY.
THE UNITED STATES PROVIDED A LOT
OF MONEY ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
WE CONTINUE TO DO SO TO HELP
RESETTLE PEOPLE CLOSE TO THEIR
HOME FOR ALL THE REASONS YOU
JUST CITE, VERY INTELLIGENT
REASONS AND THAT IS WHY WE DO
THAT.
WHY THEY’RE RUSHING THIS, REALLY
SKIPPING THE VETTING FOR MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
BRINGING THEM IN I’M NOT
ENTIRELY SURE OTHER THAN, THAT
IT FITS THE OPEN BORDERS
MENTALITY ON IMMIGRATION IN
GENERAL.
IT IS JUST BREAK THE DOORS DOWN
AND BRING ANYBODY IN.
RACHEL, WE MIGHT HAVE THE ANSWER
WHY THEY’RE DOING IT WHEN WE
FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY END UP
SETTLING THEM.
POLITICALLY SPEAKING.
THANK YOU, KEN, REALLY